يضل الساعه سته من هلا رمضان هكذا وبدردشه
بينهما قرر رئيس البرلمان والحكومه تاجيل
العمل بالتوقيت الصيفي حتى نهايه شهر
رمضان المبارك قرار رسم مشهدا سرياليا على
الحياه اللبنانيه بردود الفعل عليه يعني
هالقد في بزنس وشغل بلبنان لحتى الساعه
تاثر عليها
لانه عم نشتغل نحن كمان مع برا وفي سفر قد
يعتبره البعض موضوعا سخيفا الا انه فتح
باب الطائفيه على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
لتبدا الاتهامات باسلمه النظام السياسي
ليرد عليها بعدم احترام العيش المشترك
فيما تبقى المشكله الاساسيه فوض القرارات
والتفرد بها وفي حكومه ما في دوله والساعه
موقفه من زمان عنا اخر ه
عده عدم الالتزام بقرار مجلس الوزراء
واعلنت انها ستبدا بالعمل بالتوقيت الصيفي
في وقته الاساسي كشركات ومطاعم ومدارس
ومؤسسات اعلاميه فيما شركه الطيران الشرق
الاوسط اضطرت الى تعديل مواعيد كل رحلاتها
بعد البلبله التي حصلت اهد اول شيء اما لا
يتعلق بتدبير حكومي وانما الرب2 ما فينا
نلتزم باذر لانه كل الدراسات العالميه
بتشير انه على الاقل بدك سنه قبل لحتى
تبلغي الجهات المعنيه وخصوصا الجهات
المعنيه بالتوقيت انه هي بلغيها بالاذاب
الذي يمكن ان يتخذ ثم نحن بنتضادر كتير من
هالامر لانه نحن عنا ارتباطات بمشاهدين
بكل انحاء العالم احدى العائلات سترسل
ابنها الى مدرسته في التوقيت الاول وبعدها
بساعه سترسل ابنها الاخر الى مدرسه اخرى
بعد ان امتد الخلاف الى المدارس هي عينه
من الضياع الذي سيعيشه اللبنانيون مع وجود
التوقيتين في بلدهم ففي بلدان العالم هناك
توقيت جرينتش اما في لبنان فتوقيت صيفي او
توقيت بري او توقيت ميقاتي وحتى توقيت
اسلامي او مسيحي لبنان الذي في الاساس
اصبح خارج الزمن بازماته باتت ساعه من هذا
الزمن كفيله باشعاله طائفيا وكان الشعب
يعيش حياه ورديه ستؤثر عليها ساعه مقدمه
او مؤخره ناهد يوسف العربيه بيروت